this is one thing that conservatives
really struggled with in media is what
fox will do and what a lot of these
right-wing pundits will do is they will
poke holes in the media narrative but
they won't offer a counter narrative and
so when we have Tucker Carlson talking
about January 6th and Ray apps what he's
essentially doing is filling in the gaps
for people he's saying here's this guy
who we saw inciting arguably allegedly
right we have the footage of it that's
not alleged but whether that's something
he would be prosecuted with inciting
violence for is another story however
what a traditional Fox News host might
say is we'll look at all of these holes
in the left's narrative but they
wouldn't say here's the alternate
explanation and in fact they would say
anyone who promotes that alternate
explanation is a far-right lunatic and
I'm not one of those guys Tucker Carlson
was actually willing to give you
substance aside from the left is wrong
agreed yeah I think he did bring forward
a lot of topics and like you said points
that we would not have normally heard
from a Hannity maybe even from olora
Ingram